joining us now is the man who was middle
east minister at the time nazim was
arrested and that's the conservative mp
to myself hello to mr elwood thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning how optimistic are you that
we're nearing the end game
you know i really hope this is going to
work out giving uh nazidean's passport
back is significant it's the best news
that's come out of tehran uh in six
years from arrest don't forget the
iranians don't actually recognize dual
nationalities so the fact that she's
received her passport is fantastic news
but as you've been reporting we've had
so many false storms in the past and
not just this event but nazarene's
arrest has been caught up in a wider
geopolitical storm uh in in iran but
fantastic effort by the prime minister
by the foreign secretary in getting us
where we are today
yeah
um tell us a bit more about this debt
that we owe
to iran and how the british government
i'm guessing haven't paid it until now
because they don't want to see it as a
ransom
yeah this was awkward for the british
government prior to the the when the
shah was deposed back in
1979 we actually had a deal with the uh
with iran to sell um 100 chieftain tanks
there we took the money the 400 million
pounds but we never delivered the actual
hardware itself ironically the same
tanks then went on to be sold uh to the
iraqis who then were at war with iran
that debt has been left outstanding and
you mentioned uh i was responsible for
the middle east as minister when i
visited tehran met the family in
nazidean's family
it was raised by the tehran officials in
the same meeting as we're discussing uh
the fortunes of nazidine herself they've
always made a link between
the two and i heard your interview uh
with the foreign secretary today we'll
have to wait to see what's being done
behind
the scenes it is difficult because of
legacy sanctions to be able to pay this
money back ultimately if you pay the
money slide it across the table it's
actually seen as an arms deal um so of
course uh from that perspective it can't
be it wouldn't be allowed to go through
so there needs to be a clever way
perhaps through an intermediary oman for
example for that debt to be paid
um as you say sanctions mean that they
can't get the money um at the moment
although there had been some suggestions
by a previous foreign secretary i think
it was jeremy hunt that first uh
suggested the idea that age and or
medical supplies could be a way out it's
an awful lot of aid and medical supplies
400 million plus
interest
there's no doubt about it and i looked
at different ways of going through a
third party i spent some time speaking
with the imanis as well uh they have a
an important relationship with tehran
they could have been acted as that
conduit as well things became further
complicated because of course hassan
rouhani the moderate uh president that
we were working was was replaced by a
much you know extreme hardliner ibrahim
and but the
iranian economy is now in trouble and
they need to secure a nuclear deal uh
otherwise uh
he himself will find things very very
difficult at home i think this may have
been part of clearing the air
recognizing that having the united
kingdom on side makes sense so perhaps
if that tank deal has been sorted out
led to the passport being returned but
let's wait until she's on a plane out of
here before we start to celebrate
pleased to hear that you watched the
program so avidly uh mr elwood i don't
know if you caught our interview with
the estonian ambassador to the uk he
says that his people are concerned about
what's happening in ukraine and what
might happen to them i'm guessing
because they're under the cloak of nato
and also they have a significant number
of nato and british troops uh in estonia
things will be fine there but we can see
how what's happened has unsettled the
whole region
oh absolutely i think the penny is now
dropping i can see us eventually
increasing you know britain's our hard
power our defense budget is likely to go
up we're going to regroup as a continent
far more aware of our security concerns
and not least in eastern europe we've
entered a new era of instability and
nations need to work together this is
not just about ukraine and the estonian
ambassador and indeed others are right
to raise these concerns we've done well
on the sanctions there's no doubt no
doubt about it putin i think is is now
going to be eventually a spent force in
russia they will eventually depose
himself but that's gonna be quite tricky
it takes a while for the kremlin to
recognize that there's no future on the
international stage for a country like
russia with putin in charge but whilst
he remains in power he's gonna
annihilate ukraine he cannot afford to
lose there and the big question for the
west is how many war crimes must be
committed what extents of genocide must
we uh watch from afar before we choose
uh to step in so i think it's important
to recognize that there's much more that
we can do beyond sanctions we're still
rather risk averse in our decision
making putin will not stop until he is
stopped
um and just a thought before i let you
go on what we've been hearing from
president uh zielinski um saying he's
he's perhaps a little bit more hopeful
as far as peace talks are concerned um
the foreign secretary's saying she isn't
what's your view
well uh you know a huge tribute to
zanetsky what he's doing as a wartime
leader one of the difficulties that
russians are facing is the the sense of
resilience that the
ukrainian people are actually showing my
concern the way i read any talks that
are taking place right now is simply an
excuse for russia uh to secure more time
to rearm and regroup and then prepare
for further attacks that's what we've
seen in the last discussions that are
actually taking place i think it will
happen again i reiterate we need to be
more robust in the utility of our hard
power we need to more self-confident in
stepping forward without losing control
of that critical escalatory ladder when
dealing with a nuclear power but right
now every major initiative of support
like migs from poland is immediately
dismissed as having the potential to
trigger world war iii and this i'm
afraid it exhibits weakness and is being
exploited by putin who then continues to
test us we really do need to rekindle
our cold war statecraft skills
okay mr ellwood thank you very much
indeed for taking the time to join us
this morning thank you